and the scene at York Minster we're
coming towards the end of that service
that the King has been taking part in
there Monday Thursday of course a key
date in the Christian calendar marking
the end of Lent and the King has been
giving up Mundi money
um it's given us an acts of Charity
every year the late Queen used to do
this giving it to pensioners to Mark the
occasion something that the King has now
taken over and according to the official
royal family website the queen would
distribute gifts according to the number
of years that she's lived
so that's what's been going on in York
Minster this morning
at the ceremony the men and women
receive
26 pence in specially minted mondi money
from it's actually more than that that's
what the queen gave when she first
started so it's more than that now the
King has taken over but that he will
give that money to those special guests
so it's 74 men and 74 women signifying
his age giving them the Monday gift and
he will thank them will have thanked
them for their Christian service and
their help in local communities the men
and women had been selected from the
church of England diocese across the
country and Anglican and ecumenical
Partners across the UK that's according
to York Minster in its statement
[Applause]
foreign
from that service
and on his arrival we did hear some
protesters there from the Republican
Republic organization uh protesting at
the king's presence there
can't hear them on their exit
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
Consul posed there for photographs as
they come out of that Monday Thursday
service
a lot of attention today is turning to
this news that King Charles has for the
first time has signaled his support for
Research into the British monarchy's
historical links with transatlantic
slavery this after the emergence of a
document showing one of his predecessors
stakes in a slave trading company
[Applause]
[Music]
and this is a research project
co-sponsored by historic raw palaces
which manages several palaces into the
monarchy's involvement in the slave
trade
[Applause]
[Music]
no doubt we'll get more reaction to that
development but a spokesperson for the
palace has said that it's an issue that
his majesty takes profoundly seriously
and we did read out some of his
statement that he gave to the
Commonwealth heads of government
reception in Rwanda last year about his
own personal sorrow of the suffering of
so many as he put it
and he also talked about deepening his
own understanding of slavery's enduring
impact
[Music]
[Applause]
so there he is waving to the crowds now
who are gathered there
and we can't see some of the protesters
banners there not my king written on
those banners there
we did hear some booing as he went in to
the service
by those protesters
there's anti-monarchy protesters
[Applause]
[Music]